enter segment at least not talk about
our [ __ ] but did you see Jordan
Peterson talking to this Imam oh yeah
that was fascinating what the [ __ ] Eric
did you see it no okay I did not so the
um you should play the audio in the
recording it's it's really
the question did that happen
begs the question what do you mean by
happen
is it a is it a mom or a shake I don't
even know Islamic Theologian Shake
whatever and then Jordan Peterson goes
on this long-winded thing going well
what do we what do we even mean by God
what do we even mean by do do you
believe what do you mean by do when you
are dealing with fundamental realities
and you pose a question you have to
understand that the reality of the
concepts of your question
when you're digging that deep are just
as questionable about as what you're
questioning you know so people say to me
what do you do you believe in god what
do you mean do
what do you mean you what do you mean
believe and what do you mean God and you
say as the questioner well we already
know what all those things mean except
belief in God and I think no if we're
going to get down to the fundamental
brass tax we don't really know what any
of those things mean he's like some
people when they ask me if I believe in
God it's like well I don't even know
what that means it depends on what the
meaning of is is there an ultimate
purpose of life
yeah sure what is it what we're doing
here which is what
hopefully trying to make peace
is that enough
we'll see yeah because if it's better
than the alternative what's the
alternative hell
it's just such a slimy way it's such a
slimy like non-answer because I know
that he has convictions like strong
convictions and it's just funny when
someone asks them a question that he
would have to like make those strong
convictions he clearly has clear it's
like he doesn't want to he's scared to
but you can tell from the way he talks
about things with such Authority it's
like you do have views that are like
strong but then when someone's like okay
well tell me what those are you're like
well it's so hard because like I have no
idea it's like okay well if you're
really that unsure then why are you so
convicted about all the stuff you [ __ ]
on like it makes no sense it's like
you're clearly just being a slimy [ __ ]
who doesn't want to take give a straight
answer but he's focusing on the word do
which the do is the least consequential
word in the sentence do you believe in
God it only exists in English I mean not
all whatever it doesn't exist in French
it doesn't exist in Spanish it's just
like a helper it's an non-verb he goes
well what is the meaning of the word do
and this from the guy who's like
post-modernists only focus on language
and the meaning of words so that they
can argue and make claims about whatever
they want to deny the truth how do you
know what the true significance is of
the text now the answer to that is this
is the answer we don't know now the
problem with the postmodernists wasn't
that they figured out that this was a
mystery so when I do something like an
interrogate a question well the
postmodern problem does emerge now I've
been trying to work out solutions to
that and and Jonathan and I and John
viveki have been discussing this a lot
the post-modernists were correct I think
in their diagnosis of the problem they
left right to the idea that the way we
solve the problem of perception is by
exercising power if they just took a
Marxist story and said well there's the
solution by in particular mostly the
French intellectual types
took amongst his position at all well
Jonathan you want to have that that's
not a fight it's a worthless victory for
me are you sure yeah to talk about that
no no I don't like I don't care okay
well well we can either delve into that
or not and he's just like pronouns
taking taking issue with the most basic
functional English sentence like if
you're gonna have a conversation about
metaphysics then sure you can go into
the meaning of language and the function
of language in that conversation which
is by the way something that I would
certainly do
do do the problem there is to sit there
like we don't already have a given
context in which a conversation can
occur we don't agree on anything but no
we agree on what language is for you
understand me sounds like he just
applies a different standard to uh other
people's thinking than he does to his
own this is this is goth such a [ __ ] at
one point he says that he has come to
the same insight as darita but that
darita answered the problem of what
words mean with Marxism
and first of all there that barely uses
Marx at all except for that he wrote a
book on him in the 90s but the language
and text [ __ ] is like 25 years old at
that point but second and way more
importantly is Daria never claims to
solve the problem of meaning in language
and the point of his work is why is
there even a problem with meaning and
language and I mean he doesn't even
conclude this but the point is a
demonstration that
language isn't a container for truths or
signifies of the real world or whatever
presence
but do you do you think that when dare
does wife asked him to do the dishes
he's just like what do you even ah
dishes no
we don't have to start every
conversation by defining the words in a
sentence an intelligent people's
questions about language don't have to
do with it what individual words mean
it's how they mean that's the only thing
that really matters and that's only ever
in the context of views but I agree with
you Victor I think he I think he just
says this because he does believe in God
and doesn't want to say so so he's just
some [ __ ] to something yeah or like I
mean he's just like feels like a grad
student jerking off to like uh
skepticism well there is a daradian
point to be made there a dirty and
performance because once you define
those terms what are you going to use to
define those terms you have to use more
language the guy who launched his career
on oppositions to pronouns what do you
you mean you you now he can't figure out
what do means are we are we talking
about dare today I thought maybe we'd be
talking about Rory but I guess both
rorty on habermas and dareda well I just
thought since since I ended the last
since I ended the last episode by saying
how little I wanted to talk about
habermaster I thought it was perfect to
talk about once your strength returns
yeah exactly Victor I think I had you
pegged a little bit wrong or painted in
my head as a portrait a little bit
incorrect because I thought you'd be on
the side of the discursive the
inter-subjective and harbor Moss is very
strongly
anti-subjectivist in rorty's painting so
I kind of figured that you'd be on the
other side of this but I've come to
realize my picture's wrong about you and
that you're this is more of a fun puzzle
rather than
making the stakes as great as habermas
seems to think that they are yeah I
think that's true I mean I think I'm
somewhat sympathetic
to like a very indirect pathway that
like certain kinds of theorizing about
politics
can do but uh it's very indirect like I
don't I don't have grand Ambitions that
it's gonna like make an actual
difference
ah
um just before we get started
the article is
rorty defending
derida and Heidegger from harbormoss and
if you want to have a look at it it is
attached to the post on our patreon page
which you can see because it's public
even if you're not a patron and the
reason for that is I can't attach things
to uh podcast feed posts so it is there
if you want to have a look at it and uh
I guess initial Impressions this was a
Killer article it's very
clear pretty fun the lines of debate are
set up clearly in the debate
goes thoroughly Rory brings us through a
defense I guess of of dairy Don
Heidegger from a habermasian offensive
and it's a little bit refreshing to read
Heidi Grande offense defended because
usually they are being brutalized
unfairly for this or that reason but
also because reading Rory is just a hell
of a lot easier than it is to read
either of those guys
even if uh even if he's a little less
exciting than they are well I will
disagree with you because I felt very
excited reading this article I I found
that and you know maybe that's just a
difference in our style or like our
interests too because like you seem to
get excited by [ __ ] that is like
impossible to read you're like oh this
is making my mind go in a million places
because I don't understand it because
you're a [ __ ] freak but like I'm like
oh wow I can understand everything he's
saying and and what he's saying is very
exciting because I feel like he put into
very clear terms just certain things
that I've thought about I've thought
about kind of like this divide or I mean
I don't know if it's like a established
divide but just certain like styles of
philosophizing which you're right it
does kind of continue from last couple
episodes in the sense of it it does kind
of tackle the question of like what
approach to philosophy can we use or
should we use to talk about I guess
moral or political questions so there's
a continuity there but I found just the
way he set up this division which we'll
get into talking about kind of like the
what do you what do you refer like
people who are more sympathetic to like
a Heidegger Foucault darita versus
people who are sympathetic to like a
hypermas Rawls I think he he defines
that puts into words like pretty well
and convincingly like kind of some
difference in tendency and like interest
and then his own account I find myself
sympathetic too about like
what like what kind of reasoning or
philosophy we can do about political
problems
um so yeah hopefully we can get to all
that but I I liked it a lot it was
exciting and I did think of you by the
way I thought I thought of myself yes
there has to be a skill about this but
there's a skill to say because he's like
derida stands obviously doesn't use that
term but derida stands are gonna suggest
this and I'm like actually yeah I do
suggest that yeah but also I didn't feel
attacked by it I was like yeah yeah
that's that's pretty much it so the
paper is called by the way habermaster
and the functions of philosophy
by Richard we're already published in
1995 which will be attached in it but uh
this was soon after I think he wrote his
book uh contingency irony and solidarity
yeah I think he said this is some
material that didn't make it into that
book publish some stuff separately
yeah no I I think I agree I I find his
style like well I found the subject
matter just like interesting you know a
reproachment between habermas and dairy
dog cool like he's gonna defuse
habermot's critiques of zerida then show
why Dairy does actually like someone we
should think about that's cool and
rorty's style is I I find it interesting
clear buoyant like it almost reminded me
of
uh reading LaTour for the first time
Mike and just finding
just the style very engaging and clear
and and I think I also appreciate like
his very Cavalier approach to philosophy
and Theory like Rory is is really
you know he talks to analytics like
Davidson but he's just so like Cavalier
towards the analytic tradition he's
constantly questioning himself he's
makes these very firm statements but
then he's like also openly like I don't
know what to think about this yeah and
here I mean he did start off as like a
straight up analytic philosopher like he
did his PhD I think on I don't remember
what it was on but definitely like with
a pretty well-known analytic philosopher
and wrote on analytic philosophy and
then kind of shifted
his style and approach because he just I
mean and I always respect
like in well-known philosophers when
they're clearly like good at both like
they they've engaged in both robustly
and I'm like okay good this will be
interesting yeah like I thought his
first major book uh the the his his
mirror of nature book was was influenced
by Heidegger and he and he's clearly got
a grasp of like the Nietzsche Heidegger
Foucault
tradition like he's willing to speak to
that and unlike many of the people he
kind of Associates with he's very
willing to speak to that tradition and
find Value in it which is also kind of
refreshing I want to take a little bit
of a step back because I we've I don't
think we've ever mentioned Rory before
Rory is mostly right all the time but he
never says anything like ideologically
strong enough to be like oh that's a
rorty idea he's kind of uh
a balanced Fair Critic so this article
is habermas attacking dareda and by
extension habermas attacking dareda
Heidegger and Nietzsche he kind of lumps
them together and Rory comes in and says
I'm going to defend darada Haida
Greninja from habermas's critiques but
also some parts of habermas's critiques
are good so he's kind of a diffuser
we have this big manufactured split
between continental and anglo-american
philosophy right and you'll never catch
me dead within analytic philosophy book
for the rest of my life
because I already did it but it's
offensive to me except for Davidson who
you already mentioned but anyway I don't
know if you guys will agree with me on
this or not but I think we're we're
entering into one of the areas in which
the distinction between analytic and
Continental doesn't seem so important or
seems the least important and that is
at least what Rory calls pragmatism
because rorty's pretty hard to place for
men for reasons that you mentioned he
talks about Whitehead he talks about
Wittgenstein he talks a lot about
Heidegger but he in he writes I guess
you could say
in a very straightforward you can see
the analytic influence in what he writes
it'll be he'll he'll frame the debate
first Heidegger says this then habermas
says this then derida says this so it's
very straightforward in the way that we
might hope he doesn't seem to see the
need for a creative flowery
deconstructionist language but you know
still I think most of what he says is
fair and clear and
dare I say analytic in style I mean he's
not using symbolic Logic No which is the
worst kind but but he's but he's but
he's very clear so like I wanted to read
just like a couple sentences because
like I think he sets it up well he's
like um
yeah he's like I argued in my book uh
contingency irony in solidarity that
darede's books are just what you need if
you've been impressed and burdened by
Heidegger if you feel the power of
heideggerian language but want to avoid
describing yourself in terms of it
um and then he goes on to say on the
other hand habermas's philosophy discurs
is just what you need if you find
Heidegger and darede equally pointless
I highlighted that too
philosophical discourses on modernity or
something like that
which I strangely enough have on my
shelf yeah yeah and he says he goes on
to say habermas helps you feel justified
in circumventing the Nietzsche Heidegger
derida genre of ironist theorizing which
we'll get into what that means
um and going around it rather than
through it
um yeah I like that I I thought I
thought he just places it well like I
just feel like the way he describes
kind of like the these figures and how
they interact I was just I thought it
was very well stated and convincing yeah
one one more quotation I see Jacques
Derrida as the most intriguing and
ingenious of contemporary philosophers
and Jurgen habermas as the most socially
useful the one who does most for Social
Democratic politics
praising he seems like a a really
annoying dad to me
yeah by the way he was laid out here is
it does sound
I don't know it sounds like a way
forward if if you're sort of
writing in the what like the mid mid
late
20th century
you know habermas is like a major option
third wave critical theory Frankfurt
School guy
kind of moving towards back towards this
like project of rehabilitating
Enlightenment rationality that's that's
what habermas is all about
so we've talked about pragmatism before
and I wondered if you could kick this
off for us Eric because pragmatism is a
lot of what you study but you study
early 20th century pragmatism and uh
Rory is known as a pragmatist but he
kind of redefines it so I was wondering
if you could give us that what changed
what does he do how do we situate rorty
as an author uh well yeah I would I
would preface by saying you know I've
got a lot of my pragmatism sort of
second hand through looking at semiotics
and becoming interested in purse who's
credited as James in in the 1890s
credits first with coining the term but
James popularized it and James is also
um kind of like a benefactor of purses
otherwise purse would have would have
died in poverty much earlier than he did
and James of course is the surname of
William James William James the brother
of Henry James the writer of a turn of
the screw
uh William James is his younger brother
I believe
uh and well-known pragmatist yeah
pragmatism is known as like you know
America's one unique contribution to
philosophy this pragmatism comes so it's
good old home-grown American philosophy
uh and there's lots of its influences
made its way across to the Continental
tradition as well you know a lot of a
lot of Continental philosophers can be
described as pragmatists including
Toulouse
William James and and Charles purse very
interested in the cinema books and
elsewhere he cites them
uh and it's
you know though I I can say that the way
Rory defines it really is is just uh
it's it's a denial of um correspondence
theory of Truth
right it's a it's a different option if
you if you're if you're not happy with
representationalism and the realism
idealism debate
and you're not concerned really with
what truth is
but more about what truth what use the
concept of Truth has in our discourses
in our language games and that sort of
thing
um then you you can become a pragmatist
but in a in a sort of wider sense yeah
it is it is um
kind of a an epistemological position
you know anti-foundationalism
anti-representationalism
um it's it's non-transcendental it
doesn't doesn't go for the
transcendental option it's not a
philosophy of the subject
it's more oriented to
you know like Victor says these sorts of
things all the time like what difference
does it make like that's what basically
what the pragmatist is is interested in
is exactly what difference something
would make in practice it's not
practicalism it's not saying Theory
isn't important or politics isn't
important to theorize about it's just
gonna say you know if if it doesn't make
a difference
then it's something pragmatism won't be
interested in if it's just a abstruse
metaphysical debate that has no bearing
on improving our lives or helping us
discover the answer to some burning
question or helping us experiment and
observe and and obtain some settlement
of belief or some consensus on some
topic or issue right then pragmatism is
not interested in it so you could even
say dare I say it's an ideas don't
matter philosophy
ideas only matter in so far as they're
useful as they make a difference right
so it's it's it has a lot of resonance
for me with with systems theory and and
the post-humanist tradition as well I'm
gonna put forward that I don't think
it's a very useful distinction
it it kind of describes a disposition
towards what philosophy should be for
rather than like grouping together
people like I think all of us are pretty
much pragmatists and for sure we're
pragmatized by some definition but I've
never said hey I'm a pragmatist because
I kind of don't know what it means it
can kind of mean whatever you want but
what's the functions of philosophy the
name of this this article right it's
about this is going to be about what you
what uses philosophy yeah the function
and I think it would be useful to Define
one of his terms that he Contin
continues to return to throughout the
article which is ironism
which comes from his book
um that I mentioned before about uh
ironies um what was it called
contingency irony and solidarity
and so I like went to the actual book to
find a definition and actually this
definition is on on the Wikipedia
article about the book but it's directly
quoted from the book
so basically he says that an ironist is
someone
um describes the status of a person
holding the Axiom set out in the first
three chapters so like a person is an
ironist when they fulfill these three
things
um they have a radical and continuing
doubt about the final vocabulary
um that they currently use because they
have been impressed by other
vocabularies vocabulary is taken as
final by people or books they have
encountered
um two they realize that arguments
phrased
um in the present vocabulary can either
underwrite nor dissolve these doubts and
then three insofar as they philosophize
about their situation
um they do not think that their
vocabulary is closer to reality than
others that it is in touch with a power
um not themselves so basically kind of
rude for you to talk to me talk about me
like this when I'm right here
yeah as opposed to the metaphysician who
is quote someone who believes that there
is only one right vocabulary of moral
deliberation and one who is in touch
with reality and in particular are
essential Humanity that's the the
opposite of the ironist is the
metaphysician as as Rory plays them out
yeah exactly so I think what what's
what's interesting about that is um
well I think it like convincingly
describes the tendency of people who are
more attracted to I think
post-structural philosophy and I think
what's interesting which maybe we don't
have to get into right away is like the
way that at least for me it why I got so
excited about it
was because he he has this line which
maybe I can find later where he says
basically like when ironists try to do
political Theory
like like there's a really interesting
line there where he's like like so he
basically has this claim maybe we can we
should start from this this idea
he has this claim that
um really like ironist philosophy is a
private thing it should only be done as
like a private thing it has no real
place in like public philosophy in the
sense of like having an impact on
society
um and that like this other kind of more
habermasian philosophy that's public
philosophy that's like trying to talk
about like how to reorganize
Society how to reorganize institutions
and that ironist philosophy is like kind
of meditating on the contingency of
everything that's just something that
like you can do yourself
um but it seemed to me that he's kind of
arguing that it's a bit of a mistake to
think that you can somehow make that a
public thing which I thought was
interesting I want to correct you on one
thing because you said should
which is against the ironist position
you said it should be a private thing oh
right no he just said it is a private
thing yes so an ironist describes
according to Harbor boss or according to
Rory interpreting habermas it describes
Nietzsche Heidegger and darita so those
are the three ironists in this uh
recognized in this article and you
mentions Foucault later too I think
advico yeah he mentions Foucault and he
says
Foucault drifts most towards the social
of those three but yeah so ironic for
ironic theorizing I gotta say it just
describes me and that yeah is someone
who sees I'll defend myself I don't
think that it's as private as he thinks
it is but it describes Theory or
theorizing as a sort of a game
and it's always a game because you are
always undermining yourself because you
recognize that your ideas are contingent
so your your argument is dependent on
language you're you're dependent on
History you're dependent on like the
experiences that you've internalized so
like this is something that I honestly
believe which is why I am really hostile
to shoulds I'm really hostile to
universals I'm really hostile to people
telling other people what to do because
I don't think fundamentally that
language and Truth have necessarily
anything to do with each other I do
think they are accidentally related
but they're so interrelated that you
can't differentiate them whereas I see
from my perspective the logic Bros or
analytic philosophy even as as saying
that these things are so different that
you can either Express truth and
language or fail to express truth and
language because they are so separate
and language is then subordinate to
truth
and then you can measure the truth value
of statements and arguments and be
correct or incorrect and I see this
probably because I've read so much of
the people that he's describing as
ironists I see more of it as play and
more of it as a game and you can say
anything it it's not about what what
ultimately measures up to an invisible
Universal value that you have and some
of the some of the debates or
disagreements that we have gotten in to
the podcast over the years some of them
are equip Equitable to that difference
in view
yes I agree with that
yeah go ahead I know I was gonna say a
really interesting sort of hook onto
last week's episode as well is that
well here habermas kind of dismisses
ironism this is one of the points
Richard Rody's going to be critical of
he he calls that tradition the
philosophy of subjectivity and he thinks
it has no place no use no no political
use value because it's not a public
philosophy it's focused on the private
embroidery is going to try to subvert
that but it really does seem like what
habermas calls the philosophy of the
subject
or philosophy of subjectivity and what
Rory is going to sort of
elevate a little bit into liberal
ironism is basically what Taylor was
talking about in our last episode we did
between individualism as the
conservative alarmists talk about it
relativistic soft relativism
solipsistic in us in a way versus what
Taylor wanted to articulate with a a an
individualism that has an ideal that has
the idealization of self-realization of
authenticity and that you're not
confined to your individual value system
but these things can be reasoned about
in a in a public way but you have your
own value system as well as an
individual and you're self-defined but
you're not solipsistic according to the
conservative alarmists who are very
worried about the modern malaise of
individuals and relativism so actually
this article really reminded me of a
morality could almost be like a kind of
uh Taylor and Charles Taylor and and in
slightly different terms with very
different points of reference but a lot
of similarities I noticed
really I saw him as against what we
accused Taylor of being because he yeah
I think so the whole time he's defending
what habermas sorry for all the name
dropping listeners to but he Rory is
defending darita and Heidegger against
what habermas calls private philosophy
and to us to an extent I think he's
right but habermas reads deridan
Heidegger as bad public philosophers
where Rory says they're not even public
philosophers they are private
philosophers but it still matters yeah
and that's what they're trying to do so
like I think in a way
um he is defending those figures rorty
but I think he's also pointing out where
habermas kind of has a point or he's
agreeing and he's like yeah that's true
like they are doing that like they don't
care about those things like it is hard
to mount but he's like but that's the
point like that's what they're trying to
do he's like you're misunderstanding
what those philosophers are doing
um and I think he's just like yeah
there's lots of space for that kind of
ironist philosophy but he also to me
seems to also want to defend what
habermass is doing in a way that
probably you wouldn't be as comfortable
with pills like because it seems like
Rory is also saying well maybe this kind
of kind of Public philosophizing public
theorizing can be useful to society
right because he does
seem to want to leave space
for things that can make life better for
people and I personally found it
sometimes a little bit vague but also
appealing the way that he just wanted to
talk about cruelty and humiliation as
things that we are trying to that like
seem he doesn't even want to say like
bad or should but he's just like those
seem like motivating things that we
would want to have less of
um so he kind of he kind of has like a
way around making like strong normative
claims by just being like well
I'll see if I can find a quote but um
but he he does sort of so in a way I
think
what Rory to me is doing is like yeah I
like the ironist philosophizing I think
it's good for what it's doing
but I think he's agreeing with habermas
and some others that you know it's kind
of dumb uh it's kind of like it can lead
to a kind of quietism where you don't do
anything it's like that's your whole
world like and you need to have some
public awareness of like cruelties and
humiliations and horrible things that
are happening in the world and should
not be scared to talk about how those
things can be improved and in that case
you can use a kind of philosopher like
habermas to talk about that
can I I can respond to that I think
because I'm not hostile to universals
until the universal becomes a weapon by
which a philosopher tells me how I
should live
so I'm I'm an I'm an edible
I'm a resistant edible figure who just
wants to overthrow the father all the
time and I honestly I agree to an extent
with what Rory's saying here you know
because private philosophy matters a lot
to me I think anyone who's heard me talk
for any amount of time knows that and I
think that
the word private however is
emphasizing the wrong aspect of this if
this makes sense because I have called
it before a sense
and my sense is mine
in the so it is private
in a sense of a sense
but also I find it to be General and I
think our listeners have probably heard
me speak a lot about sense like our
culture has a sense our technology
creates a sense and
like ultimately it's this sense of
alienation that we have as
intellectually curious people in a world
that is arranged like it is but I also
think that the sense is real so habermas
and Rory agree on this and they want to
call it private philosophy and to an
extent it is private but I think it is
privately shared I don't think that I
would have an audience if that sense
wasn't privately shared because
according to their definition everything
that I am concerned with is private
philosophy not what the world should do
not how the world should look but my
sense of what the world is so irony at
least to me is an expression of that
shared sense and ideas don't matter is
philosophical ironism but I think
there's more buy-in
than anything that's just
individualistic or solipsistic
I think that if you express that sense
of alienation properly then other people
will realize that you're right and if
they don't
then I don't care I'm not concerned with
conversion yes see this is where I don't
see a whole lot of difference between
what Taylor was saying about about
Rousseau and how he reconfigures
um that sort of what was it called
Sensational sensationalism before him
into a kind of
aesthetic inward looking activity that
becomes a model for good moral behavior
and what Rory is describing here as as
private philosophy kind of beginning
with Nietzsche he's a good Pro he's a
good private philosopher but he gets rid
of that idealist focus on solidarity
and he's interested in escaping the sort
of burden of tradition in order to
expand the potential of of what the
individual can be I I really I I see a
huge parallel between the way that Rory
kind of traces ironism back
to post hegelian philosophy
and the way that Taylor traces kind of
the origin of of individualism
to like Rousseau and I also noticed a
few times Rory invoke this kind of
public talk
and like talking to each other right
which also reminded me of stuff the
tailor and I remember reading and being
like uphills is going to hate this stuff
about like more another philosopher
saying like we need to talk to each
other but I think what he means is that
like it's through that talk that you can
only come to realize
humiliations cruelties in the world
um and that's why he also taught like
talks about literature
um as one of the forms in which the the
value that literature brings is to make
is to bring new sensitivities to people
to realize like the experience that
other people go through I think he
mentions you know
could these you know civil rights
movements and and these things like you
know the overcoming of slavery been
possible without any lists a few books
right that talk about the first person
account of being a slave and
so so it seems like he wants to make
some space for like the importance of
discourse uh in in the world right and
like he includes I think literature but
also something that he kind of vaguely
deter defines as just like public talk
talking to each other
so I felt called out here when just now
no no no in in Reading what you
described we read the same thing
obviously but I felt like okay why why
am I an ironist as opposed to a public
philosopher
and what they're calling public
philosophy I realized through
self-reflection I don't trust it
and I don't trust it
because capitalism
right right wait what you're just gonna
give me that one
I'm guessing we just lost 20 of our
listener base for that [ __ ] take but I
mean capitalism ironically as to mean
more than you know capitalism it means
where are we gonna have this spirited
public debate that you're talking about
are we gonna have it in in uh newspaper
articles controlled by you know five
companies are we gonna have this
spirited public debate on a platform
that's that's worth x billion dollars
are we gonna have this debate in
neoliberal University departments who's
hiring practices whose publication
practices don't seem to have anything
necessarily to do with truth and
establishing the truth between groups of
people they seem to have completely
exterior interests
and I guess interest like conversely to
both Harbor moss and Taylor I don't even
trust myself when it comes to being
outside of those interests
and you know that's the ironist position
to a T and it's something I also happen
to believe so
I don't trust the public sphere in the
way that Taylor and habermas seem to
because I don't I see it as corrupted
and I don't even I don't even trust my
own thinking going out there you know I
don't think it's insane to think that
your discourse will be driven by the
same motives and desires that are
required to succeed in a particular
system at a particular time which is
once in a while maybe something like the
truth with a capital T but more often
not
I think that's my answer habermas wants
to talk about
uh universally valid public space you
leave your beliefs at the door you just
have discourse and I think I don't have
faith in that because I have so much
faith that I am not the protagonist of
this story and more importantly truth is
not the protagonist of this story but
perhaps some other system is but do you
think that Rory has faith in that
because he still wants to make room for
this kind of public talk like rhodi
himself but I don't think he wants to
Define it in the same terms that
habermas does I think for him it's like
very much particular problems social
problems right he that's why I think he
talks about like things that other
people might like analytic philosophers
might call like moral wrongs or like you
know injustices he just says like
cruelty humiliation right like things
that are concrete right that he's like
and we can talk to each other about
those things
and be and then from that talk can be
like well let's have this concrete
action that can end those things in this
case right and like incrementally change
those and that's why he talks about like
slavery and and civil rights as like
instances of that process happening
right but it's not because you have some
Universal you know point it's because
you're actually immersing yourself in
the concrete cruelties and and
humiliations and right all those things
yeah like concrete descriptions of
suffering or or
asymmetries that you bring home and
people see them and then they sort of
realize rather rather than the sort of
universal validity method where you come
up with with universal principles of
action or or you commit to some sort of
overarching cause some greater something
or you attempt to transform human nature
so such that you know there's a kind of
freedom from oppression from anything
external freedom from social oppression
totally right he says that that's kind
of a very misguided view that would be
almost like taking taking the private
without the public at all which he's he
sees as a kind of danger but I think the
best way he contrasts the private and
the public with with habermas as he says
where where habermas sees a contrast
between his socially useless exhausted
philosophy of subjectivity on the one
hand and a socially unifying philosophy
of rationality as inter-subjectivity
rorty he says sees a contrast between
the private need for autonomy yeah and
the public need for and this is how he
reconfigures the public here he says the
public need for a synoptic view of the
goals of Democratic Society a society
held together by an agreement event in
rawls's terms to give the right priority
over the good or to make Justice the
first virtue
that's that's how he frames his like
distinction so Haber must completely you
know discounts the ironist the private
yeah autonomous anything any autonomy
from the public sphere is is for
habermas socially useless philosophy
yeah and Rory also calls it like the
public part he just calls it public
problem solving at one point too which I
think is a useful way of thinking and
actually he says on page 450 you know
there's no reason to think we have to
choose between Dewey he's talking about
Dewey in this case and derida between
public problem solving and private
struggles for autonomy the two
activities can co-exist peacefully
there's no reason why philosophy should
have to choose between them nor any need
to assign one some sort of epistemic
priority over the other the choice
between the two activities and any given
concrete case is no more susceptible to
the application of General criteria than
is any other painful conflict between
duties to others and duties to self
yeah I gotta say I'm I'm still
comfortable where I'm at
well isn't he saying that that's fine
well if it better be fine he's gonna sit
there and say like your type of
philosophizing is useless and my type of
philosophizing is useful show me where's
your results Mr habermas what is what is
your public pursuit of Justice un
uncorrupted by personal desire where is
it where's your results
this is what is embarrassing about
making reason a world protagonist
because it's so obviously wrong
and harbor Moss obviously I called him a
dad earlier I think that's indicative of
my anti-edible Tendencies there because
just he says reason is going to be the
mediator here and Rory is much does yeah
Rory is much more pragmatic in saying
well we can't do anything on our own so
yeah do your ironist philosophizing but
make sure you're attentive and looking
for Solutions also and that's where I
was like you know what Rory you you can
be my dad you're okay
yeah yeah concrete every time that
happens I go well what what am I
supposed to do about it and that's
the question that I never push myself
sorry to get all like autobiographical
here but that's the question I never
pushed myself far enough it's like does
this problem have a concrete solution
and I always go nope capitalism's gonna
own us if we even try to step outside of
our door but I also did agree with this
depending on how hard you want to make
it this distinction between private
philosophy and public philosophy because
like I said the sense of private
philosophy can be publicized enough to
make it
shared not Universal but shared at least
well I think that's a that's actually a
kind of a I I don't know I wouldn't say
you can just get rid of that aspect of
Rory though that distinction between
private and public is kind of a problem
in his work throughout his work right
that the like his notion of of pragmatic
pluralism that kind of jamesian type of
or even kantian pluralism whatever you
want to call it
is is based on
you know the private being separate from
the public the public being a kind of
homogeneous space where reason prevails
not not reason grounded in Universal
validity but the reason of concrete
problem solving and the what's next kind
of point of view being actually
confronted with problems and kind of
like casual history on a case-by-case
basis and then the private spear being
the Locale of of of all of our different
internal lives and our that's what the
philosophy is subjectivity the private I
mean I think that's a problem you're
putting your finger on it's not just
something that can be like oh I don't
like that distinction but I like Rory
it's like no that distinction kind of is
rorty in a way and it's it's problematic
I think a homogeneous social space in
which all of our private problems can be
brought to bear just not in a
habermasian kind of inter-subjective
Reason way but
in a synoptic view of the goals of
democracy kind of way
it's it's problematic
can I if I can give just a a banal
example
uh a songwriter who writes a song about
an experience that is a private
experience like whether or not it's true
it doesn't matter just it's based on an
experience and they put their feelings
to music and this this music resonates
with thousands of people
millions of people
and I wonder would that be something
private would that be something public
because I personally as you know see
philosophy far more close to something
like artistic expression than something
like rational expression so how would
that fit and if if we're dividing
philosophy into private and public
that's ultimately a question about what
you think philosophy does and is for
right well I I interpreted him to mean
by private
like kind of an internal
like like that it that its location is
mostly I mean I know the internal
external distinction whatever
problematic but
like so I guess like one way to think
about it is just like I was sort of like
self-help in a way it's like it's like
you know you can be more at peace with
yourself if you take up this ironist
philosophy like you adopt an attitude
that is particular to you yes you can
share it with other people you can talk
about it you can be like okay like I
find Value in this too just like you can
do with art
but I don't think like it's so I don't I
think that's distinguished from thinking
about some public institutional problem
or like some broad structure that is
like causing you know enjoy like causing
injury to people
that is like publicly experienced and
seen that's different than just oh like
I find a lot of use in this like I don't
know I'm gonna use yoga as an example
which like you can share it but it's
still kind of like private in the sense
that it is like you actualizing your own
sense of self and sense of awareness in
the world uh that is to me is different
than this kind of public problem solving
that he's talking about which is like
alleviating these Collective problems of
like cruelty and so it's I don't think
he meant by private that it can't be
shared I just think he meant like where
its location mostly is I mean
did mean that
I mean thank you for that it makes it
more clear but I mean that's how I
interpret Rory anyway I think this is
like what
how does the private sort of function is
where we have to be a little bit careful
um but again this is why I sort of saw
that resonance with Taylor is because
because the private is somewhat
analogous to you know you were just
talking about listening to a song I'd
say you know aesthetic artistic creation
poetic language right like World
disclosing is is the business of you
know well it's like a Heidi Gary in term
World disclosing or getting away from
logocentrism what the ironist wants to
do is is tear themselves away from that
that tradition that is trying to force
Conformity upon them and create a new
language right these new vocabularies
and that's poetic like you know rorty
takes this idea of metaphor from
Davidson and metaphors at first are this
sort of surprising creative thing that
that are a sign of original thought and
you can't really argue about them but
once once they become a little bit
solidified once they become a little bit
you know static they become metaphors
become literalized over time and then
that's the point when you can bring them
into the public sphere and and have
recent discussions about them but at
first meta the Productions of new
vocabularies metaphor poetic language
the model of poetic language that's
that's where the private is that's Dairy
done Nietzsche and Heidegger's role here
for Rory is is being good private
philosophers which means which means
this poetic World disclosing language
that habermas completely dismisses
because it's not that concrete
problem-solving language it's not
literalized like havermas wants it to be
but Rory valorizes that
and that's just blatantly true you just
look at any etymology I think it's neat
or dairy to quoting Nietzsche says that
our philosophical Concepts they're just
coins with the faces rubbed off they're
all metaphors that we forgot
are metaphors and we're talking about
truth this whole time very seriously now
truth in English is different from these
other
languages uh French and German but in
English truth
etymologically goes back to the word for
a an oak tree just because it's solid
and this is what I'm always thinking of
is like if you want to take these words
so seriously and not take the poetic not
take the expressive not take the world
disclosing seriously you're just
forgetting
how language got to be this in the first
place you're taking it for granted yay
there's a distinction between the world
disclosing and the problem-solving
functions of language
and derida and Heidegger are on the side
of the world disclosing but habermas he
says quote thinks that darita denies the
existence of an independently structured
domain of everyday communication
practice right so that's you know
habermas's posts
vicensteinian side right that there
needs to be this everyday language of
communication that we can all
participate in because obviously
language can't be private language is
not private language is something that's
shared between us that's how we
understand each other
and that's this sort of the point
wickenstein makes in philosophical
investigations so there's no such thing
as a private language but there's still
a kind of
poetic
creation that goes on here and and
that's why I thought it would be being
being careful because again he says
Dairy dad doesn't deny the existence
of
this autonomous domain of everyday
communicative practice Dairy doesn't
need to
because his point is about
you know well writing and the trace and
which which is not a theory of language
specifically but it's a more it doesn't
it doesn't presuppose a theory of
language is what what he's getting at
here Dairy does dairy does on Dairy does
side it's it's a it's a really difficult
Point yeah quote
darita does not belong to those
philosophers who like to argue unquote
yeah yeah he yeah he doesn't he doesn't
do the public reasoning thing
because but but Harbor Moss hits him for
this
because he thinks Dairy does just trying
to collapse
language into this this amorphous sphere
whereas
you know it's it's difficult here when
you're not familiar with some of these
American receivers of darita's
philosophy because it's hard to know
what you know like Paul Damon has sort
of done with darita and Rory is kind of
disapproving of how dareida has been
received in America and then Rory thinks
he has a better version of of derida and
he's going to present him here because
Daria doesn't need to make any claims in
that argumentative sense because
derida's theory is not a view of the
nature of language
but it it can't be criticized by
reference to any theory of meaning
theory of Truth theory of language
because that's not what derida is doing
so it's it's it's a difficult point to
tease out without writing an article
about it
yeah for sure
um
I think he says something really
interesting about
uh which I wonder what pills is take and
actually Eric too and he says he puts
four he's like I put forward a contrast
between an intellectual World dominated
by the German longing for some higher
Destiny than that of Nietzsche's last
man and one dominated merely by the
Anglo-Saxon desire to avoid the
infliction of unnecessary pain and
humiliation
in terms of the distinction between the
sublime and the Beautiful and then he
says radicals want Sublime Sublimity but
liberals just want Beauty
um so I wonder what you guys made of
that
because I thought that was kind of
interesting and he goes on to say
something which
um radicals want a world in which all
things have been made new and in which
the rearrangement of little private
things the pursuit of idiosyncratic
autonomy is subsumed under some higher
larger more thrilling communal goal they
want a public version of the sublime
Sublimity which I have been urging in
this chapter is by its nature private
the Sublimity one attains by breaking
out of some particular inheritance of
vocabulary tradition or Style which one
had feared might bound one's entire life
I don't think it's possible to make a
public version of that
I I think like that that's going to be
the goal of society like to take care of
everyone that's Sublimity
well we should Define what he means by
this because he says that the radicals
want Sublimity and the Liberals want
Beauty
uh in case anyone's not on board here uh
those are kantian categories where the
beautiful is something that you notice
is good you realize it's good and the
sublime is something that is beyond good
it comes from the outside and just
demands your submission to it so the
radical
in this sense wants Utopia they you
could just say they want the end of
capitalism they want a world without
alienation and that's like their goal
whereas the liberal just wants Beauty
which is another way of saying the
Liberals utilitarian they if they see
someone suffering they'll you know kind
of try to stop that suffering and once
that suffering is done then we're all
good but I think this actually belies
something a little more
dark which is I'm sure if the liberal
doesn't see it then it's not real and
our liberal version of capitalism has
worked we have the beautiful world we
have our entertaining Electronics we
have food from anywhere and everywhere
that can show up magically on your
doorstep we have cheap [ __ ] clothes
exploitation wage slavery actual slavery
what are those things and obviously I
think rorty will say we shouldn't be
okay with those things we have to be
ethical still I guess but what is the
use of a conversation about Universal
ethics on this point and where's the
moral obligation to see what we can't
see even if we saw we have a no free
choice to stop it because in one sense
we already have the liberal world he
wants we can just live in the beautiful
go into the university philosophy job
get tired do some teaching do some
marketing come home watch some sports oh
look I live in the beautiful world and I
roll my eyes when these guys talk about
solving concrete problems because once
again they're making reason or the idea
of freedom into a world protagonist
and no matter how you want to slice it
talking to each other does not change a
supply chain yeah I mean so I think that
ultimately Rory ends up coming down in
this case on the side of the liberal but
that's why he spends so much time
talking about
identifying those sources of suffering
and humiliation and cruelty
that's why the work of talking to each
other is important that's why the work
of literature is important because then
we can see those things right and it's
and I think that he so where he's with
dareda is yeah like coming up with a
grand theory of like good and evil like
that's stupid that's a waste of time all
you need to do is describe
um to bring to the Forefront that
cruelty and suffering you don't need to
have like a theory about it but he's
still on the side of the liberal I think
in the sense that like that's really
important like we need to draw attention
to Cruelty to suffering to all those
things that he wants to talk about yeah
he does make some descriptions he says
like in this world he's imagining where
we don't have radical social theory
in this world we would have what he says
here is a switch from an ideal of
universal validity to linguistic
historicism which would encourage irony
at the expense of metaphysics so ironism
here and it would encourage a sense of
contingency of final vocabularies so
again it comes back like he's a
linguistic he's he's operating in the in
the wake of the linguistic turn here so
he's like the contingency of final
vocabularies rather than escaping this
contingency and and getting that sense
of finality
and he's so he he does and and that that
like concrete descriptions of pain and
humiliation
rather than what he says we need that
rather than running together
the diminution of pain and humiliation
with the idea of transforming the nature
of man he doesn't like this idea of
transforming the nature of man this this
sort of internal welling up of Sublimity
that's going to burst its seems and
change the world he doesn't like that
yeah so you're you're again you're
sitting on the couch watching reality
television that's that's just your
chosen path okay or you're just sitting
around reading de losing guitari like
that's not going to change the world
either right like it doesn't have to be
reality TV show I think he's actually
saying something more specific at people
who just want to read radical Theory all
the time or something like that like he
even he has a great a point on the last
page
where he says
um instead one will put most of one's
hopes for the relief of unnecessary
socially continenced pain and
humiliation in two things first the
sorts of writings I listed above novels
articles and reports by those who are
able to make specific kinds of pain and
humiliation visible second proposals for
specific changes in Social Arrangements
EG in laws company regulations
administrative procedures educational
practices etc etc this means that terms
like late capitalism modern industrial
society and conditions of the production
of knowledge will be employed less
frequently in terms like worker
representation laws against unproductive
Financial manipulation and journalists
Union more yeah dude he's he's calling
out we've left our friends the Twitter
marxists alone for a couple episodes
but he's calling out the Twitter Marxist
because the Twitter marketers say unless
you're a radical rhetoric like
rhetorically only unless you're a
radical rhetoric Marxist arguing for the
overthrow of capitalism which he would
call here the sublime is the end of
capitalism then you are a lib you're a
lib reformist and we don't want you you
are like AOC and [ __ ] you yep but he's
saying we're already saying you know you
can have that sense of Sublimity
But ultimately the only thing that's
going to change the world is this
pursuit of beauty or the pursuit of
utilitarian goals make a few things
better for a few people that's better
than sitting there and saying we need to
overthrow capitalism and then capitalism
doesn't end up getting overthrown and
everyone's life is the same
yeah or just be more specific yes I
agree like it is that but that requires
a kind of like particularism in the
sense that he's like talk about
particular problems in particular
circumstances and particular solutions
that are appropriate to those
circumstances right so it's like there's
no universalism about moral wrongness or
rightness it's just like this specific
thing needs to be fixed because of these
contingent reasons and we just need to
look and be aware and bring those things
into visibility but like forget about
these big buzzwords or Buzz terms right
about so I love it I mean I think this
is this is like
this is like my view I feel like what
he's saying here is like I feel very
um close to to his view here
well if I can push back on it since you
since you buy it what does the what does
philosophy have to do with any of this
because
I'm gonna I'm gonna be the Twitter
Marxist I guess I am kind of the Twitter
Marxist but I'm gonna be the Twitter
Marxist and say no matter how much you
talk no matter how many conferences you
put on Journal articles you write
capitalism ain't gonna give a [ __ ] it
doesn't matter how much you bring to
light it doesn't matter if you do a
documentary on the horrid working
conditions in in Chinese factories it
doesn't matter how many Oscars parasite
wins it doesn't matter how many dramas
like made come out on Netflix it doesn't
matter how many leaked exposes of
political corruption
are released you've had the chance for
your reformed Enlightenment and yet
we're more alienated stupider poorer
than our parents were because social and
legal decisions are made where there's
accumulated Capital now where there is
rational conversation so if you're gonna
do philosophy you might as well do the
fun interesting [ __ ] instead of the
pretentious we are the ones who change
the world because we are the Agents of
reason and history type of philosophy
yeah I mean look I I've said from the
beginning that I'm not I don't think
that doing philosophy is going to solve
these problems and in fact he doesn't
even really like list philosophy
um
as
like one of the main ways of bringing to
light these you know socially
experienced sufferings and pains
right like that's why he actually he
actually favors like the novel
um or like artwork to bring those things
to the foreground like I am doing
philosophy in the way that I'm doing it
because I think it's interesting and fun
to argue about but I don't think it's
going to solve any social problems
um as I said before but I do think uh
but I'm so I but what I'm with them on
is
like focus on specific things
um like when it like like if you're
actually serious about solving like
problems that are gonna make people's
lives better like you kind of need to
get serious and like learn about policy
and learn about the policy process and
learn about how those decisions are
actually made uh concretely on the
ground
his view of
you know I mean he straight up says it
after the first division he says you
know my view the nature and function of
philosophy is a pseudotopic
he thinks of it he thinks philosophies
is a basically a pseudotopic here
he's not he's not interested in a theory
of meaning that leads to a theory of
Truth
he's not interested in Universal claims
to Universal validity he's not
interested in a Universalist project
as as many sort of like marxists and and
even you know Marxist to sort of work
against maybe the postmarks is current
are into a project of universal humanism
and we're already
doesn't like that he he he's he's all
for a philosophy of the subject it seems
in the form of this ironism
and he he he kind of reproaches habermas
for dismissing philosophy of
subjectivity
but he also sees this
philosophy of subjectivity merely as the
creation of new vocabularies
and and then those vocabularies starting
out as metaphors and hardening into
literal
become then fodder for articulations of
of public reason in order to solve
specific problems
and that's a sort of the the cycle of of
rorty's like reasoning here and in a way
but he's you know he he makes a lot of
assumptions about I mean this
public-private distinction I think is
problematic he assumes a kind of
homogenized public sphere
why you didn't say specifically why you
thought the private part was uh
problematic you just don't like the
homogenization or the the assumption
I think the separation is a little bit
artificial but she says something about
it though and the public
he says something about that and I'm
going to try to find it um
yeah please do because I'm yeah like I'm
I'm still a little confused about how
those two spheres would like interact in
this picture how how does the private
sphere and the public sphere interact
how is how does the non-metaphysis the
non-metaphasician the ironist you know
how does this
private not language but this sort of
poetic World disclosure become like
politically you know like uh
operationalized
well he says this near the beginning
that this public private distinction is
something that Enlightenment philosophy
contributed to philosophy because you
wouldn't find that in
in like the Greeks say their philosophy
would only be considered public
philosophy but he said this uh
Enlightenment philosophy and Romanticism
and the back and forth there split
philosophy into
uh both a private aspect and a public
aspect and people like Kant for example
they are in both they have a foot in
both
and then with Romanticism and Nietzsche
then we have a split off that just
becomes like pure private philosophy
that says the public what the hell am I
going to do with that
um Hegel would be the public side of of
nature if we're going to make that that
division
but in contrite he would Kant would
appeal in his ethics Kant would appeal
again to that sort of like you know the
the ethical principle the the
um the the the maxim right which is a
kind of like a non-human thing it's a
universal like the self-legislation of
reason and and Rory doesn't want that
Rory doesn't want the private sphere to
have a kind of have a privileged access
to some kind of ethical principle some
kind of um so he's he's sort of against
this this
um this deontological approach
oh yeah for sure but I'm just saying he
he says the enlightenment introduced
that distinction and he's still finding
that distinction useful
you can see it in that
actually he uses it backwards but you
can see it in the use of the sublime and
the Beautiful because of the sublime is
everywhere must everyone who ever sees
this must agree that this is Sublime
whereas Beauty can be like based on your
personal taste and private
but in any case he thinks uh yeah
habermas wants to give up one side of it
based on his reading of
derida and yeah I guess we're being
going down the middle again here
so he's taking a kind of he's taking a
conciliatory approach he's taking a nice
little centered view yeah I mean I yeah
I appreciate the effort I mean I think
what I think it's rare to also find
someone do that but I feel
that he's being pretty fair to both
sides
in a way which I was impressed by like I
was impressed but even though I don't
know habermaster that well it's just
like because he's he's obviously still
kind of Defending some of habermas
um but then he's also defending right
dareda and in fact he's not even I
wouldn't even say I wouldn't even put it
the way that Eric put it which was that
you know he's you know he he's
criticizing uh like like Hopper mass for
being too public necessarily would I see
him more but although that was implied I
think really what I would see in Moore
is doing is really like defending dareda
and Heidegger against the unfair
criticisms that habermas shoots at them
right he's kind of I wrote that in my
notes like this wasn't a concealer
reconciliation he was just defending one
against the other yeah but I think still
ex but still like clearly he's not an
anti-habermasian right I think that's
one of the differences like you're right
normally you would see someone who would
want to defend dareda and Heidegger
against this kind of a a critique would
be like a hyper you know diridian who's
anti-habermasian like that would be more
normal where he's not that at all he's
kind of like well I see the value in
Harbor Mass too I just think he's wrong
about this right yeah I enjoyed it as
far as it goes and I think he summarizes
like his problem with habermas perfectly
when he says habermas over dramatizes
the contrast between subjects centered
reason and communicative reason and
habermas looks for signs of
subject-centeredness in everything that
he claims the status of philosophy
everything that claims the status of
philosophy without being socially useful
he thinks he that's his
critique of but anybody affirms all
kinds of elements of habermas he thinks
that philosophy or at least
linguistic historicism in in lieu of
philosophy should be publicly useful but
then again I I just I'm not entirely
clear on how we get how those two
spheres interact the the public and the
the private or the how communicative
reason and linguistic historicism should
should with their proper relationship to
one another should be yeah I think he
deals with this more in the book on
ironism and I don't remember
this distinction being that heart as
harsh as he kind of lays it out here and
I can't tell if he's laying it out
harshly because
um he's quoting Habra Moss or whether he
takes that view I just have to mention
like the cover of that book I find it
kind of weird
that like I don't know if you guys are
seeing the cover of contingency irony
and solidarity if you like look it up is
it it's just so weird that like he
decided to put it yeah didn't know that
he just decided to put himself on the
cover like it's just like him that's
probably the publisher and I find that's
so weird I don't know yeah I guess so I
just like why would you approve that I
don't know like here's like the
Wikipedia article I just like like what
philosopher just puts themselves sitting
in like a garden
on the cover it's just I find it so odd
I don't know a distinguished Woodland in
a white suit it's just odd to me it's
like well that's I don't know yeah he's
got these funny pictures floating around
with him out there like him doing the
sort of Look Back The Smiling look back
and things like that yeah I mean I I
would throw it out there that you know
Rory has been accused of of being kind
of ethnocentric overly valorizing you
know modern liberal democracies seeing
that seeing those as the model that the
rest of the world should follow
and there are you know good critiques
from the left of rorty coming out I
would just read one example I find found
from Chantal moof
um saying that rorty's
rorty's identification of the political
project of modernity with a vague
concept of liberalism which includes
both capitalism and democracy is a
problem if one fails to draw a
distinction between democracy and
liberalism between political and
economic liberalism if as Rory does one
conflates all these Notions under the
term liberalism one is driven under the
pretext of Defending modernity to a pure
and simple apology for the institutions
and practices of the rich North Atlantic
democracies and so you know he does and
and he does he makes the chauvinistic
Point even in this article it's not hard
to you know suss out Rory says to be
bluntly chauvinistic about it this
switch would emphasize the Anglo-Saxon
utilitarian reformist brand of social
thought and de-emphasize the German
ideology critique brand so he does have
a kind of he does have a kind of
bulldozer liberalism he is very
chauvinistic by his own admission and he
is you know
he's he's got a he's he's all down with
the liberal ethnos he's an ethnocentric
thinker he's in the American tradition
so it's not surprising in that sense
yeah though the white suit in in the
garden is made he can watch an extremely
dry kind of one of those old school
philosophy overdose couch sittings of
him with Donald Davidson
it was it was actually quite
enlightening but but my point is to be
more radical
well last thing I wanted to still shove
one thing here and at the end he gives
this defense of uh derida and I wanted
to bring this up just because for our
our listeners sake 98 of what anyone
says about dareda is wrong and I know
that I sound like a Stan I guess I am a
Stan okay okay you're kind of what
derida says this about truth Dara makes
this claim about language like they're
so rare that he ever says anything so
they are ascribing that Rory describes
this like halfway through the article
people think that dareda doing this
little performance of deconstruction is
him making claims about truth and all
that and that comes from daredev's
interpreters who like Damon good
interpreter like says pretty much but he
puts derida's performance into the
language of a thesis or the language of
a conclusion like derida is saying this
when he does this but almost all the
time that is the reader adding to the
performance and saying this was derida's
intention and there it up more than
anyone else I've ever read is very
careful to not State his intention
he will put it out you can read it how
you want you could say this is a
performance you can say this is a
declaration of Truth you can say he's
making an argument you can say he's
drawing a conclusion but he very rarely
does that on his own yeah once in a
while in interviews he does but almost
never when he's writing he's very
specific about his and well doesn't he
actually doesn't he actually blame some
of the misinterpretations that habermas
has on these readers of dareda like he
says that in the article doesn't he yeah
they they take Dairy down make them out
to have like a metaphysical point or a
point about the nature of language or a
philosophical project what's all those
bullshitters in English departments
they're [ __ ] ruining derida the
English departments well Jordan Peterson
does this Charles Taylor last week did
this it's like derida says this and
every time 98 of the time I should say
he didn't say that he didn't say that he
didn't say it he didn't say it anyway so
you're saying that you're saying that
you're saying that horrority was good on
this point right in interpreting him
Rory actually has read derida you can
tell yeah rorty's great on that
he's he's he says these when you take
darita as the Americans did and try to
like work out like metaphysical claims
he says all that that becomes fodder for
people like habermas to just just drag
them their arguments out of the private
into the public sphere look at them as
bad public philosophers and then come up
with these reasons why their arguments
are incorrect when Rory as we already
said darita is not one of the arguing
philosophers
and an inconsistent philosopher like
myself will say I'm not making
metaphysical claims and then go and make
metaphysical claims but derida is not an
inconsistent philosopher he's very
careful not to do that yeah
in such a short piece you know he said a
lot of good great things and I love you
know someone who's actually willing to
bring derida and and treat him as
complementary to the main point rather
than as a as a foil and honestly like
I've never read someone that I've been
closer to being like this is the sense
in which I'm a lib is like Rory like
that's the closest I think that I've
seen someone come up to or to like
another philosopher and a robust
pragmatism that doesn't fall into that
simple you know practicalism and
anti-theory kind of like anti-theory of
the 80s yeah kind of no he's he's down
for theory he you just have to
reconfigure it in in a certain way to to
uh be ironist theorizing I guess you
could say
and ultimately we're all Libs anyway
especially the ones especially the ones
who say they aren't the the screechy
ones they're the most live of all trying
to impose their moralist language onto
everybody else who exists on the great
disclosed world the world of shared
sense
that was a that was a good episode
I'm happy with that good pick Vic yeah
I'm happy it turned out all right yeah
rorty's a lot of fun actually I enjoy
reading Rory you know for our purposes
it was good uh listeners you should you
should read it
I said should yeah I know but you know
it's a good sport it's worth a read how
about how would that just adjust my
language accordingly
with a contingency solidarity an irony
or whatever that contingency irony
solidarity yeah
all right thank you everybody thank you
[Laughter]
all right we will see you
yeah see ya
sir
[Music]